oh my god John oh my god you're here too
that's good yeah they told me backstage
like you're gonna do this with Aquafina
and I was like thank God I'm not
presenting alone this is my first time
ever at the Oscars like ever ever this
is my first time ever at the Oscars - oh
my god yeah yes I'm having a panic
attack I am so scared why am I so scared
right now
it's like you see these commercials and
they're like oh it's Hollywood's biggest
night and I'm always like whatever shut
up and now I'm here and like this is
Holly there's Hollywood's biggest night
it's a big night I want these people to
like me to a degree that I find
embarrassing yet who are you most
nervous to see because when I walked out
I saw Spike Lee and I was like what
that's what she said yeah I was I know I
was like he's like that's great
do you know my side you know I saw in I
legit free hello Jordan Peele don't you
know him yeah that's why it's weird all
right this is awesome let's do this we
are here to present the award for best
animated short sued they gave us one of
the big one a big one it's a big one
here are the nominees for Best Animated
Short Film animal behavior
allison snowden and david fine
bow domi she and Becky may Munhall late
afternoon
Louise Bagnall and Maria Gonzalez Blanca
one small step Andrew says worth and
Bobby Pontius weekends
Trevor Jimenez and the Oscar goes to bow
[Applause]
this is the first Oscar and nomination
for DOMA she and Becky Nieman Cobb
Academy Awards in this category have
been presented since 1932
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
um holy it's our first time - yes I'm
Christine - oh my gosh um thank you to
the Academy thank you to my fellow
nominees thank you for supporting shorts
to all of the nerdy girls out there who
hide behind their sketchbooks don't be
afraid to tell your stories to the world
you're gonna freak people out but you'll
probably connect with them too and
that's an amazing feeling to have thank
you to Pete docter for believing in my
weirdness and for giving me a voice at
the studio and thank you of course - you
know my mom and my dad my my muses and
my partner Darren for being with me for
all of this and being my human stress
ball thank you we want to we want to
thank the entire bow crew they brought
their heart to this short and you can
see it in every shot to everyone at
Pixar you inspire us every day Disney
for believing in us - my friends and
family parents and sister I love you so
much I got to make a short help make a
short that was about a mother just as I
was becoming one so to my little bow
Lucy and 2dn none of this would be
possible without you
[Applause]